it is very hard when you're establishing
a relationship to be long distance and
I'll give you a few examples like you
kind of pack it all in you sort of move
faster than you think you should
um you know you have you you may or may
not succeed at finding inventive ways of
getting to know each other and
communicating
establishing a relationship in Long
Distance rather having a long-distance
relationship that has been established
we should have more patience with that
process because it's a little trickier
oh it's trickier but it's doable it is
all doable yeah and long distance for
Ebbs is not sustainable right but but I
would say don't eliminate somebody out
of contention because they're long
distance agreed agreed agreed agree and
then be patient about the start and the
build totally and then you know you'll
find a routine and a pace that works for
you